[Music]
so I'm Emily Thomas I'm an assistant
professor of philosophy at Durham
University and you're currently writing
a book about the philosophy of travel I
am yeah it's almost finished and the
book explores various ways that
philosophy and travel have interacted
from the 16th 17th century onwards it
seemed to give you a few examples
Francis Bacon back in the end of the
16th century came up with a new
philosophy of science where he thought
that rather than staying at home and
sitting in armchairs in order to learn
about the world what we should be doing
is going out into the world through
travel and collecting all kinds of
strange creatures and fossils of plants
that and then we travel we could bring
that knowledge back home and from that
figure out how the world really works so
I think that was one of their earlier
serious engagements with philosophy and
travel but there have been lots and lots
more for example like John Locke thought
that if we can use travel literature to
understand how the human mind works he
thought that if humans really have
innate ideas then every human being the
world over would have the same ideas
about morality in God and of course
travel shows that that is not the case
at all and people around the world have
really different ideas so he's using
travel to argue against innate ideas it
also covers things like the ethics of
visiting doomed places in places that
are changing dramatically through
climate change and lots of us want to
see the icebergs before they melt and
see the coral reef before you know
they're destroyed by rising sea level
temperatures but the very act of
visiting these places might actually
hasten their demise and so that becomes
a moral issue sure we want to see them
that maybe we shouldn't be
so is is your philosophy of travel book
than focusing more aglow on the ethics
of travel it's a real exploration their
travel and philosophy in general right
so it it works chronologically from the
very earliest intersections of travel
and philosophy and then moves forward in
time so it looks for example it and
Henri through has lots to say about the
notion of wilderness in his book Walden
I look at the notion of maps like what a
map is what philosophy can tell us about
that and then ethics is just one of the
many issues facing philosophers today so
if you were to take three things that
philosophy tells us about travel what
would they be in terms of like what we
should or shouldn't do when we when we
travel or why wait that's really nice
okay so I think philosophy definitely
tells us that travel can be a source of
knowledge that it can be mind expanding
lots of philosophers have actually
compared going on a philosophical
journey to going on a literal journey to
distant lands I think what they're
getting out there is that we need to
expand our minds that that's a really
good thing for us to do I also think
that thinking about philosophy can help
us travel more mindfully it can help us
understand the cultural and ethical
significance of the kind of journeys
that we're going on and why we're doing
them in the first place and finally I
think that philosophy can tell us I'm
expected think about why we travel I
snow for example up until the early 18th
century people didn't visit mountains
people weren't very interested in
mountains they thought that they were
ugly warts pop marks upon the earth
there was a sea change in the way that
philosophy thought about landscapes and
that seems to have led to a massive
upset in mountain tourism what
originally changed their mind about was
the nature
space right so in this 17th century you
have a theory becoming really popular
and it's actually a theory that I will
be talking about here and it was held by
Isaac Newton and it's the V that space
is a real kind of thing it's a thing
that has a topology and properties of
its own
Newton identified space with God and
that meant the infinite places are
associated with God they become divine
and what you get because Newton was so
popular is a whole succession of artists
and poets and writers who then begin to
talk about infinite looking places like
mountain escapes and ocean escapes as
being divine so suddenly mountains
rather than being these warts upon the
earth become cathedrals to God and it's
definitely a reaction to the way that
people's conception of space has changed
okay and then another topic that you're
gonna talk about and the festival is
time would you be able to tell us and
what your research has focused on yeah
so I think what time is is one of the
biggest questions that philosophers can
ask it's one of the biggest questions
that humans can ask and I'm just as
fascinated by it as everyone else there
are different ways to work on time and
philosophies so one way is to what I can
contemporary metaphysics really try and
dig down and maybe into the science or
into the philosophy and ask what time is
but what I'm really interested in is how
theories were invented and developed in
the history of philosophy so I've just
finished a study on absolute time which
was it very invented in the 17th century
which says it's a kind of thing and
Newton also wants to identify absolute
time with God so again time becomes
divine what I'm working on right now is
a new book and it's gonna cover late
nineteenth early twentieth century
philosophy and it's looking at the way
that debates we have today things like
does time really pass is there something
special about the present moment how
those debates were invented and
developed and I hold a controversial
view which is that these debates were
actually invented about a hundred years
ago I don't think people were talking
about that before and I think there's
something special about that period that
really drove people to ask does time
flow does time pass and I'm interested
in how they began asking those questions
I think there are a few different things
that happened one was the view that time
is an unreal illusion became
phenomenally popular partly through the
work of people like Kant and Hegel that
it was really picked up in the
anglo-american world and everyone just
began denying the reality of time and so
they really believe that at the
fundamental level it then did not happen
before or after one another and I think
there was a massive reaction to this
that a whole other group of philosophers
suddenly began saying but that's crazy
of course things happened before and
after one another what's more we feel
like we're in time and then you get this
hodgepodge of science is feeding into
the philosophy so psychology is becoming
really popular for the first time I mean
it's really being developed as a
discipline there's lots of interesting
work going on in physics this is before
relativity so things like Minkowski
saying that space and time should be
unified as a four-dimensional space-time
there's also the biological theory of
evolution which took some time after
Darwin to filter through into philosophy
the in Darwin we have scientists
seeming to say if you give time long
enough it can
a new species it can build mountains and
I think that philosophers really began
to take this stuff on board they really
began to think of time as a kind of
powerful force and then that led them to
to stress this notion that time really
flows it really passes and then you
start getting the debates going between
the philosophers on the one hand you say
time does not flow or pass and
philosophers on the other hand to is
saying it definitely flows and passes
the other subject that you've focused on
even women on metaphysics I was
wondering whether you could bring one or
two examples of female philosophers and
if you discovered and admire and run us
through their ideas very quickly so up
until 20 or 30 years ago people would
commonly say there were no women in the
history of philosophy up until maybe
1950 women just didn't do philosophy
they didn't exist then over the last
20-30 years there's been a huge recovery
project to go back into the archives and
old books and say actually no there were
quite a lot of women floating around and
what's more they had really cool
philosophical things to say so for
example and the philosopher and Conway
she's active in the mid 17th century
she has a reply to Descartes
account of what the world is so
Descartes thought that our world is made
up of bodies and minds that these are
two different kinds of substances that
that raises a big interaction problem
for one thing if God he was supposed to
be a bigger material mind interact with
the world how is God an immaterial being
creating things like bodies and then how
are our minds interacting with our
bodies it seems like there are two
interaction problems there then Conway
just wants to solve this by saying
everything that exists is fundamentally
immaterial and she gets rid of both
interactions in one fell swoop and she
builds up this picture of the world
little immaterial creatures that are all
interacting with each other in different
ways some might seem a bit more like
mine so we're a bit more like bodies but
fundamentally they're all the same
living thing for motivates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute's of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you